all right hi everybody my name is
Stephanie Kim and yeah I'm going to be
talking about how to become a more
productive and efficient data scientist
by kind of taking some of the tips and
tricks from the software engineering
world let my clicker did work but now it
doesn't so I will have to do this
manually all right a little bit about me
and I use Python R to do data analysis
some machine learning projects
specifically natural language processing
work kind of looking at feedback form
data and any kind of user data to get
some insights about using the user
interface where people are having
problems with I've done some ETL at my
old job at Apollo education group I
founded Seattle PI ladies location I am
currently the organizer of saddled
building intelligent applications
Meeta so it's a group just trying to you
know kind of come together and figure
out how do we can make smart
applications together and I'm a
developer evangelist to algorithm-- yeah
so just a little bit about where I'm at
right now
at albers mia we're a common API for
algorithms functions and models that run
as scaleable micro-services
so we're powered by a great community of
developers researchers and organizations
that all contribute to the platform to
make the marketplace just really robust
and have status of our algorithms
accessible and discoverable by everyone
so you can think of those as the bridge
between the researchers who create the
algorithms and the developers who want
to consume them so we have more than
2,500 algorithms that run is
containerized microservices and kind of
think of them as LEGO building blocks of
algorithmic intelligence that developers
can use to you know create share and
remix at Yelp we have a ton of utility
algorithms such as scrapers file
converters - deep learning algorithms
such as nudity detection profanity
detection
and video processing pipeline so you
don't have to build those pipelines
yourself for data scientists or any kind
of algorithm developer you can host your
algorithm and you can host your data and
pickled model for free and you wrap that
in a function and we turn it into a
scaleable API endpoint for you in just a
few lines of code and you have CPU or
GPU machines available to you you can
open-source your algorithms or you can
make it private to consume it yourselves
within your organization or you can
monetize your publicly available
algorithms so what is a 10x developer so
it's someone who is literally 10 times
more productive than the average
developer it means not only can someone
produce more code per hour than the
average developer but they produce less
bugs say they also mentor they write
documentation they have a lot of read
skills that go beyond just knowing how
to code brief history so behind this
idea so in 1968 sakhalin Ericsson and
grant um created a study they looked at
programmers who had an average of seven
years experience and they discovered
there was a broad range of time that
took each of them to complete a code of
silence and later there were more
studies done that kind of found the same
thing so even though some you know these
people had about the same you know level
of experience in years and background
their wide ranges of time it took to do
the same coding assignments so there is
some controversy about the study about
whether these types of developers really
exist people often say oh hey you know
women can't produce baby and you know
ten women can't produce a TV in one
month but it's not a linear process
coding is in a linear process I
especially like an analogy from
the article the 10x developer is not a
myth where the author gives an example
of Sherlock Holmes being the equivalent
of 10 average detectives but we're not
going to focus on the debate whether or
not exists I've I've met developers who
are much more productive than your
average developer on a team and so I'm
going to you know give you the what I've
learned what I've learned you know from
other people and then of course
different articles on how to be more
productive as a developer and apply
those to the data science workflow so
hopefully by the end of this talk you
will walk away with definitely some of
those skills and be as productive as
these kitties we're going to cover at a
high-level project design like I
wouldn't means too you know maybe step
back and and look at the project
holistically before you dive in write
any code we're going to look at tricks
of code design to be more efficient and
productive which tools for the job might
help you know you be faster and you know
just briefly going over production izing
your model the skills that not all of it
have but it can you know round out your
your toolkit to to make you more
efficient productive and viable and you
know if there's more data scientists out
there in the job market
so project design the first couple
tenets are knowing the business domain
and understanding the question that
stakeholders are asking understanding
the goals so knowing the business domain
whether you're in education biotech
finance it's it doesn't mean that you
have to know all the ins and outs of
what that business does but you should
understand what factors could change the
outcome of a data model by understanding
the business at a high level so an
obvious example would be to understand
how different factors affect sales
volume so you might be improperly
interpreting sales them if you're
ignoring some factors such as weather
as an independent variable in your
analysis and maybe you're only looking
at discounts and other marketing effects
efforts that affect sales volume so say
you've got like a food truck you know
and you're trying to optimize for
location and in that example if you
don't account for the weather you're not
going to have a very strong model it's
just a very basic example so more
importantly than understanding the
business domain however is understanding
the data how it is extracted when it was
extracted by whom
what bias is there might be are there
gaps in the data what features have used
and what I might be missing and other
you might have other data sources within
the company that you could potentially
add to create a more accurate model and
so kind of leads us to the next point
it's understand ask but it's also talk
to people talk to people within you know
the the team across team and learn from
one another because you you might be
able to understand more about not only
the data but the the goals of the
business so ask questions you should
understand what the business owner or
product manager is asking for one of the
biggest things of any you know project
is understanding what the business
owners are asking you to do because they
might not know themselves they might
have heard some cool you know term that
you know their competitor you know oh
they're using that model or oh they've
got a recommendation we need that so you
need to ask questions and learn what are
you actually trying to achieve with this
so it's important to you know have that
have that in documentation so you can
reference it and so you can really
solidify your own conceptual model about
what the the goals are of the business
so how does how to use make you attend a
data scientist so you first the first
tenant of like that great productive
developer that we're talking about is
they only want to do the work that needs
to be done
Alvers are lazy right
they don't want to do more than they
have to and sews by stepping back you
really get a good idea about what work
needs to be done and what you can
actually skip you can also find
misunderstandings between what you know
the business owner thinks they need and
and you know what you say they you know
okay well maybe this isn't the best
thing for you have you tried this and
and sometimes we're caught in the trap
of just wanting to build something cool
because we want to learn how to do it
but to be more productive and more
efficient you really should take a step
back and say okay well what does this
mean to the business so and again you'll
just solidify your own conceptual model
by taking a step back before you write
any code and learning you know what what
the goal is so the next idea is code
design this is probably the biggest
section of the talk with some code
snippets so bear with me but I guess I
have a little bit of beef with some data
science scripts that I've worked on and
particularly our users I don't don't
always have the best code they don't
follow the best practices or coding
principles so the first one is clarity
beats being clever so this means try to
avoid that nested dict comprehension
with a list comp within the list
comprehension with some you know
conditions keep it simple keep it flat
so in this skull example you've got it
the first one is a you know we're just
using sort by method is no big deal but
all three of these examples do the same
thing but the first one your brain has
to really think through each step like
okay what is any of this mean and so it
takes a little bit longer three through
but you know I mean if you've been using
Scala forever you're like okay the
understand
underscore the shorthand for an argument
named in an anonymous function yeah yeah
I got that but you still have to think
through it the second example at least
uses an argument name it's showing
assignment and we can see that sorting
you know by the next last element in the
sequence X I'm going to get crazy and go
for the less obstructed naming
convention and use a name that
represents what my data is so close
count and so the third example you
immediately know what it's doing what
data is referring to and it's just a lot
faster to comprehend what's going on
especially when you haven't looked at
the code for a while
[Music]
which kind of leads us to naming things
matter and it's hard so just using these
rules of thumb a thumb use use naming
conventions found in your specs in your
language tag like Pepe data science
actually is pretty good about this
because most most people will use the
conventions like say model the variable
names model fit predicted and people are
pretty good about following those
conventions but I highly recommend you
do because your grandma's should be able
to figure out what you're referring to
so instead of the sequence X you'll want
is a user names you want it to represent
the data so this is going to make you
more productive because debugging is
faster refactoring code goes by way
faster especially again because you
probably haven't looked at your code for
a while and your team members will love
you because they don't have to go
through line by line and try to figure
out what your code represents this one's
real brief just be consistent in your
code so don't use both camelcase
and you know or snake case don't use
both in the same script but this goes
beyond just in the same script it goes
you know think of your think of each
piece of code as your you know name
stamp on it and so you want it
consistent you want to be able to go
from one project to the next and have
your naming conventions on the same
across the board you want to have your
documentation similar from project to
project because again it just speeds up
you know thinking through what is
happening in your code so this is my
beef with our users nobody uses
functions but please use them they're
really handy you can't have testable
code without functions you will have
tons of global variables and you will
have code that repeats itself often so
they should be small
that just do one thing and you should
abstract your functions to so you can
reuse them so it follows the developer
convention is dry don't repeat yourself
and again it'll speed up your
development time a lot so this one's not
as well known even amongst developers
but I have worked under some incredible
developers who ant before they sit down
and actually like write the real code
they use code stubs and so it's kind of
a way to think through what you're doing
what your project is doing what the
input and outputs are what you need to
return and it'll help you avoid
spaghetti code so documentation and
comments so doctrines and comments are
really important so obviously it helps
yourself and others know what each
function does but there's something that
I actually recently learned within the
last year that there are different
libraries and most languages available
where you can actually turn your doc
strings into readme documentation so
Python there's the library stinks so if
you hate writing documentation the very
least you could do is just use a library
to convert your actions and comments
into documentation now for a larger
project definitely have your
documentation and you know a more solid
form whether it's you know read me a
wiki whatever you want to do read the
docs but it's easier for yourself and
others and on so your teammates will
still be talking about you after you
leave the company if you have well
documented code
another I guess particular type on
developers are pretty good and you know
they do they do exception handling but
again our users I'm going to poke it at
you guys wherever you are please use
exception handling you're going you know
I don't care if you just raise an
exception and put a you know like a
helpful error message you're going to
debug your code so much faster your
again people who come in after you are
going to be amazed that you've taken the
trouble to actually handle your errors
and users they need those errors they
need helpful error messages to tell them
what's going wrong so this is the old
function so I wrote for like a year ago
this at least is in a function right so
there's comments there's some exception
handling but just quickly looking at it
I can see that it could have been broken
up into two different functions it could
it should be in it there should be a
function that just creates a plot and
and then there should be a separate
function that uploads that file so it
doesn't take a whole lot of time and
again it just really helps you create
testable code that's easy to read and
easy to understand
and this isn't a real popular one for
anybody whether you're developer or a
data scientist developers are a little
bit more known to do this but write unit
tests you should know what your code is
supposed to return and you should test
that any kind of change you make later
on if it breaks the test you'll catch
that before to Ada and everyone will
think you're amazing and this bug free
you know creator of these wonderful
models because you've taken the time to
test your own code this particular
example is from The Hitchhiker's Guide
to Python and it uses the Python testing
library PI test but there's a ton of
others I've used knows very very easy to
use all right so the right tool for the
job and sometimes there's a little bit
of hesitancy I've noticed the data
scientists to use say pre trained models
or AP is that because they like to
create the model themselves that's their
job that's your job you know and so if
you're using some pre trained models and
you know maybe you just feel like okay I
you know could be like obsolete and you
know X amount of years but developers
have been doing this forever you know
whether it's you know Stack Overflow
helping you out and you're just copying
and pasting some code or just using a
helpful library or API don't reinvent
the wheel don't think that you have to
build every single thing yourself so say
you have some Twitter data and you need
sentiment analysis there are train
models out there for you to use so you
could train your amol you could label it
and train it or you could just utilize a
pre train with model and it's not going
to work for every case but something
like social media analysis there are a
lot of useful libraries out there
um so automation tools like I'm pretty
sure we've all were in a bash script and
you know we've automated that with a
cron job and you know getting out some
reports and quick-and-dirty
but after you spend some time trying to
debug a report that was written by
someone else maybe who's left the
company it's automated and you don't
know where the job is even running on
what machine is running from so luckily
there are better ways so you could use
puppet chef ansible to help schedule
your jobs in a centralized location so
chefs has a little bit of a steep
learning curve and it's kind of labeled
as you know a more of administrative
tool DevOps tool puppet you would need
to probably learn either Ruby or pivot
DSL for the CLI commands that you would
need to use to run your jobs but ansible
is written in Python it it uses yeah Mel
commands but it's not as mature as the
others it doesn't have like quite the
you know solid community and probably
not as many like tutorials and community
help but it's definitely more user
friendly
so developers know their environment
they know an in and out so whether it's
Python environment you're using virtual
environments or using you know Conda or
you're using SBT for Scala bills where
you you know you've got your Java they
even know the database is like okay well
am I using am I you know extracting data
for [ __ ] or a sequel database like
postgis so they really know the ins and
outs of their environment and so they're
able to debug that themselves they're
able to set up faster and you know there
aren't always problems that come up that
are in your code it might be some
dependency and they know how to you know
fix that so whether it's installing an
Oracle driver on a Mac knowing all the
environment variables you have to create
or installing matplotlib on a Mac
certain versions don't show the plot
immediately so you know just knowing the
ins and outs of the environment that
you're working in and and honestly I'm
going to you know shout out to them
because there's nothing that's faster
than just opening up them for really
quick code edit in this script but you
want a full-fledged ID if you're you
know working on bigger projects I
personally like these these are kind of
my three favorite so I'll use our studio
obviously for our IntelliJ for whether
it's Scala or Java or rust I've been
known to touch creamish every every one
so that one's great and then again them
for really quick like ENL fixes and
changes in your scripts whether it's a
bash grip or Python script
so this one's a little bit looser of a
topic these are you know kind of extras
that are you know that either I read
about or that I've learned from talking
to really proficient developers so one
of them is simply pattern matching
pattern matching so this comes from
experience and it's just simply knit
like having dealt with a similar problem
before but tanks developers are able to
understand and see you know like that oh
there's some similarity within this
problem and I've dealt with this before
and hey we can you know use this example
to do this and so it's just it makes you
a little bit faster and again that one
is a little bit hard because it just
comes with the years of hard-won
experience the second one is learned to
explain your code to yourself and others
so it's important to like everybody
knows whiteboarding you know interviews
are horrible but they're you know very
common and you need to learn how to
explain your code but also you know
whether you're doing pair programming or
code reviews you need to be able to
understand what you wrote and not just
know that that's what Stack Overflow
said to do so get used to talking about
your code explaining it and then you
know sometimes that will you'll catch
your own errors I you know whether
you're you buy a developer's act you
know on Amazon and just set it on your
you know table and tell the deck what
you wrote or you know you get someone
else and explain it it definitely is
worth doing practicing this one I
personally have a hard time doing and
I'm sure I'm not the only one but you
have to learn how and when to quit and
start over with with something so
whether you you figured out you or you
heard about a model that does whatever
you're trying to accomplish a lot faster
then
and then what you started using it's
okay to quit and start over you it's
again hard to abandon that work but if
you if you've actually saved yourself
time in the long run by okay say this
this way is going to take me two weeks
to do but if I keep going down this bad
path that I am on it's going to take you
know like a month so don't be afraid to
start over and just toss away your code
and this one is probably one of the best
that I've seen from really proficient
developers they've got their own stock
of just so they've got all these little
code snippets that they know they've
used problems that I've run into time
and time again and it will definitely
speed up your workflow if you've got a
well-organized stock of code that you
can go back to and and this goes I mean
sure I might have like some scripts that
do something similar you know but kind
of condensing them and organizing them
in one place is definitely worth your
time so take a weekend and just go
through all your code and take things
that you've you know run into before and
definitely make your own stock
so not a lot of data scientists that at
least I've talked to have actually
productionize their own code a lot of
times you're you know going to be on a
team where you just kind of hand it over
and it's really important to know at
least what it takes to productionize
your code and what language use I mean
are you really going to want to project
some eyes your art code or after you
throw it over to the other team are they
going to convert that to Python or
another language that's more performant
so by again talking to other team
members or other teams and understanding
what it will take to get your model in a
production eyes environment is really
important and people definitely you know
not only respect you but they will they
will come to you and ask okay well you
know how can we you know what do we need
to do to set up on our end and you know
and you can work together so it's
important to kind of learn the language
at the very least so here's just a brief
list of some providers for posting your
data models and production izing your
code because you might end up at a
startup or you don't have a team to kind
of toss it over the wall to there's a
lot of I've checked out pretty much all
of these not so much Domino lab and
continuum but they they all have their
strengths and weaknesses things that
could be deal-breakers for you
when you start to look at these
different providers are of course ease
of use like some of them take a lot more
knowledge and research and understanding
till you learn how to use them and then
some are just super simple you're just
you know like calling an API endpoint if
you're just using you know one of their
pre trained models and you know others
like Rackspace say they only have GPUs
on
they don't have GPUs available in the
cloud so you definitely want to
understand you know the ins and outs of
those cost is really important to
everybody so you want to look at what
what are add-ons and what are the
built-in costs of like the virtual
machine that you're using some charge
you for hosting data some don't so
definitely check out you know she's got
huge files and models that could get
pretty expensive so also some are some
will lock you in to only using their
platform and a lot of us like our own
tools and we don't want to just use like
one particular vendor for what for
everything so another one do they have
the language that you use and that's
really important
last time I checked like Google Cloud ml
they had tensorflow models only for deep
learning and I believe they only had a
couple languages available but it was
including Python I know is your ml a
house Python and R and so you know you
really should understand like okay do
they support everything I need so again
like tell being able to tell a story
with your data is great but you should
understand like where it's going after
you create your model
so I mean I think most of us probably
don't feel like we're going to be 10x
helpers anytime soon like Richard from
Silicon Valley most of us probably feel
a more like we're a little bit like
bighead but that's okay we're getting it
so again just to summarize like you
should understand what tools you can use
for the job even if you're not building
them all yourself it's okay to not
reinvent the wheel use you know train
models if it makes sense for you your
use case become a master of your chosen
environment and that means like yeah
you're going to have to know you know
all about the dependencies and
environment variables and all the yucky
stuff it you know you don't want to
touch you should plan ahead and not only
in your project design but in your code
design as well and you should especially
understand the business request and and
maybe you will end up building anything
at all maybe it's not a data science
problem that needs to be solved by you
maybe it needs to go to another team and
again that's okay you don't have to take
it all on yourself to do especially if
it's not furthering the business goals
they will appreciate it and you'll you
know be working on things that are
important to the business and again just
you know learn at least at a high level
what it means to put your model in
production because that will affect your
decisions on what language you say you
know you know Python and R or you know
SPARC are you wanting to learn SPARC and
you're realizing that you know you need
real-time streaming data and so knowing
kind of like what you know your project
is going to be used for will definitely
affect your decisions
so I harass somebody jate keynote and
asked to take a picture of back of his
shirt because
I think it was from PyCon year or
something but anyway it's pest 20 the
Venice Python and yes I did ask I didn't
just sneak and take the picture but I
was like oh my gosh this totally
encapsulates everything I'm trying to
you know like help bridge you know from
the developer world so data scientist so
beautiful is better than ugly so that
kind of goes to the the clarity to
cleanly clean this versus cleverness
explicit is better than implicit simple
is better than complex complex is better
than complicated and it goes on flat is
there the nested remember I mean I love
my nested list comprehensions like
anyone else I can read them you know
very clearly once I write them and then
you know two months later I go back and
I'm like oh gosh I need to just break
this out so it just goes on readability
counts and it goes on to talk about
Python specific rules but I think most
developers kind of try at least to to
follow these tenants a little thank you
so I gay I'm giving you guys a promo
code for algorithm-- yeah to sign up if
you want to use it gives you $50 free
credit thank you for coming i think i
speeded along pretty quick so we have
some time for questions if anyone has
any thanks Stephanie
[Applause]
questions
and cute so one of the suggestions you
made was making it your own stock of
juice so how exactly would you go about
organizing that and storing them and
where that's a good question you know
the question was about how would you go
about organizing and storing your just
so I just use github gist but it's not
the best way to organize things always
because there's not
it doesn't cleanly you know organize
them into topics or something so I don't
have a good answer for you I'm
definitely not the most organized person
I'm like you know creative chaos but if
any of you have some trick that you use
to organize your gist feel free to speak
up and but yeah I unfortunately don't
have an answered that question because
they are kind of like in the sea is just
and I'm like oh jeez what's data science
and with front-end development and
what's back in development so that's a
good question and you can't I will look
into that for you and my email is
Stephanie at algorithm-- yeah so you can
email me that question too and I can
talk to team members and see if they use
anything better than yes
I just wanted a real quick I'm working
on kind of doing something like that I
like to make decorators and just a few
different Python scripts here and there
and just push it to a library maybe put
it on tip just so I like have access to
my like external brain and things that I
spent time doing in the past awesome oh
yeah you mentioned something about
exception handling and I was wondering
if you could maybe expand on some best
practices for that cuz I often find
myself when I try to do something like
that I you know imagine all kinds of
cases and type-checking and stuff and
it's like wow and spending more time
writing this and I probably would be
saving debugging or something like that
sure so the question is on exception
handling making it clean and concise
instead of just you know this huge line
you know line after line of different
trying to handle all these different
exceptions so there's a couple ways of
doing that so you can use like just say
if you're using Python you can use you
know just all the exception handling
whether it's like input/output exception
but I actually tend to like the library
that I'm using using their exceptional
line because it tends to give you a lot
cleaner exception and again the only way
to really avoid like that is to go to
using functions making them small making
them only do one thing and one thing
only because then you're only writing
exception you know for like one thing
and that's the best way to handle that
and again that means you're going to be
able to test that code as well because
you've got a function doing multiple
things it's not really testable
hi Stephanie thank you very much I'm
just wondering do you have any
suggestion about arm establishing your
business case and getting buy-in on your
projects oh that's an interesting
question
and so he asked about getting if I have
any suggestions on getting buy-in to
specific projects that you're wanting to
do is that correct yeah um it depends on
where you're working bigger companies
you have to jump through a lot more
hoops
I would suggest creating a presentation
and in doing the research yourself and
maybe even doing a little bit of the
code on the weekends which I know it
kind of feels weird but it shows that
you're committed to it it shows that
you've thought of the different problems
that you might face but it also shows
the business owners what solutions it
solves and and the fact that you're
taking initiative really makes you know
people happy if you're working in a
start-up like me it's a lot easier you
know I could just pull my CEO aside be
like hey I've got this idea and it could
solve this problem and can I do it and
you know if you get a lot more immediate
feedback and you're able to kind of you
know take risks I feel a little bit
easier because I work at both Apollo
education was a large company algorithm
is a small start-up so but it is so
again it depends upon on what your
environment is like but either case
again creating the deck doing that
research yourself and showing you know
and doing a lunchtime like a brown bag
talk especially if you're working at a
larger company that definitely that's
showing the initiative a lot of times
you know that's all it takes for people
to sign off on stuff I think we have
time for one last question and seeing
none Oh
so you mentioned earlier knowing when to
start over it's kind of hard I've
struggled with that too but I was
wondering if you can maybe elaborate
maybe what makes it hard yeah okay yes
so he asked about you know my feelings
about you know starting over and maybe
some tricks too to actually do that so
yes
starting over is hard because you've
you've committed you've invested
emotionally and in just time into
whatever you're doing and sometimes it's
hard to you know pull over off that road
because of the commitment of your time
and energy and emotion and nobody likes
to be wrong either and it's okay to be
wrong and say you know what this isn't
the right way to do it and whether it
was someone else kind of coming in and
going hey this might work better or
whatnot or if it was your you know idea
to and your research that found
something better it's it nobody likes to
be wrong but I think that's something we
all have to get over you go Lisp
programming and and be okay with being
wrong and taking a step back and saying
okay there are better ways to do this
and again sometimes that just means you
need to take a break and walk away from
the code itself and think okay what's
the way the pros and cons you know if I
keep going down this road is it going to
be really faster in the long run or did
I find a faster way to do it and I'm a
regular you know purger of my
environment I get I delete stuff all the
time on my desktop I get rid of stuff at
home I encourage you to practice that in
your life really because it it's it
makes your practices you know just
scrapping code that you spent like you
know two weeks writing a little easier
if you're used to doing that in other
parts of your life Thank You Stephanie
hmm yeah thanks guys
you